if a white student for example says to a
black student a racial slur then
it the Cod ofish now let's jump over to
the view I'm giving you a warning can we
warn the people we got a warning there's
some sort of yep there you go it's a
certifiably crazy person noted racist
who gets everything wrong and as she
admitted last week no one in her family
likes her Sonny host uh
defending the three College presidents
as they say oh there in Israel believe
they can I can I just weigh in here
because um you know I think this
this what uh Alise stonic the
congresswoman was talking about and what
this entire hearing was about should
have been about free speech and free
speech and although many people may feel
uncomfortable with it the most hateful
and heinous speech is the most protected
speech okay campuses have not been good
for free speech well so but but they
have been actually has one of the worst
records what you heard was them saying
what is completely accurate under the
law it depends on the context so if
someone does yell at a crowd racial
slurs or calls for genocide in a public
place in a crowd that is protected
speech one onone confrontation if a
white student for example says to a
black student a racial slur then
it's the codes ofish not talking about
the law though but the codes of conduct
must adhere to the law so go than the
law protect students no it it it really
can't go against the constitution in the
United States so when we're talking
about this one-on-one type of thing yes
that is when that conduct leads to
harassment and could be actionable by
the university and that's exactly what
har as it you have to commit side to be
able to condemn genocidal language like
that's a that's a dangerous slippery SL
I cannot believe it I cannot believe it
I am going to defend what's her name
what is her name Alyssa Farah yeah she
was right and she also pointed out I
cannot believe it I cannot believe it
it's a Christmas miracle Not only was
she right there about do you have to
actually commit the genocide then have a
problem as she points out this was about
the school's code of conduct Sunny host
who I'm told is a lawyer who should have
she should have her head examined and
whatever law school gave her a degree
probably should look into how she got
that degree in the first place she's
making the argument about the First
Amendment the first amendment has
nothing to do with the school's code of
conduct when you go to a school or you
go to a place of work they hand you a
pamphlet or someone in HR department
emails you something and they have
certain things that they expect you to
abide by what's our one rule in this uh
operation over here in the Ruben report
Studio no short I don't don't want to
see anyone's legs while I'm trying to do
a program that's the one rule here you
want to make fun of trans people you
want to call out for the genocide of
Jews in this room we're going to be
pretty uh liberal with that sort of
thing but I just don't want to see your
legs while you're doing
it so this has nothing to do with the
First Amendment so every single thing
that Sunny said there was a lie also
this odd distinction between if you
harass one if you say to one black kid I
I'd like for the genocide of all black
people and of course she uses the
example of the white person saying it
right because she doesn't want to do
actly what's going on here and be like
generally a bunch of either Arab or
black or something are saying some stuff
about the Jews or just broken
purple-haired you know white trans
weirdos something like that so she makes
it about the white kid going after one
black kid but it's not about one-on-one
you can't say it's a three black people
I'm going to kill you or you got it you
got it but this is the nonsense that
passes by the way I want to give credit
to the blonde on The View that nobody
knows to right nobody knows her name it
doesn't matter but she says college
campuses haven't been good on Free
Speech which that's really what this is
all about they've flipped their whole
narrative on Free Speech overnight so
that they can go after Jews and buy
extension white people right so for
years we've all known they've been
horrible on Free Speech the second now
so she says they haven't been good on
free speech and sunny has the G to say
yes they have brain damage
truly